Whoa, I'm tiny!
Look at me, I'm tiny!
Why am I so tiny?
What the fuck?
I don't know how I fucked that up.
Look at me, I'm baby.
Holy shit, I was so tiny guys.
It was called optical illusion right there.
Let me fix this.
I'm gonna do a magic trick again guys.
That was my second magic trick.
Wait, give me a sec.
Also, thank you for the five bits.
Thank you Foget!
Tier 3 for five months in a row.
Can I get some barf nights real quick for Foget?
Let me fix this real quick.
My thingy is broken a bit.
I'll do a magic trick.
Watch this.
I'll do a magic trick with me.
BOOF!
CRIMBO!
Thank you for the tier 2 as well!
Woo!
Can I get some barf nights for Crimbo and Foget today?
Holy shit.
Alright, so let me say hi to- oh god I was so tiny.
I have no idea- I don't know how I fucked up.
I always fuck up somehow.
Every time I start stream.
I would like spend like five minutes trying to make sure I don't, but it always happens.
Doesn't matter how many times I prepare myself, I'll fuck up anyway.
So I was like, let me say hi to everyone.
Taluki Liquid, Matheo Ice, uh, who else?
Sneak- uh, Sneaking, Victor Zeno Crimbo, Foget, Lancer, uh, Major, Cryptic, Acer, Foget, Fluffy- I know I think I pretty much repeated people's names already.
I already forgot who I said hi to.
Gilgamesh, Acid, Starry, Lcrunchy, Ninten, ABOX, P.D.F.
Hello everyone!
Hi!
Hi, hi, hi.
Cheetop, hi guys!
Okay.
So, guys here in Foget.
I hope I didn't find her today.
I know it's a Z too.
I was so tiny.
Dude, that was magic.
Alright, so let me tell you guys about what I know about this game.
I know nothing about this game.
I just know it's a puzzle game.
And I was like, damn.
I had four hours of sleep, guys.
Do you think I could do this puzzle game with four hours of sleep?
I was like, here's a flip-flop for you, Vox.
Okay, can we help you?
I mean, sure, please.
I think I need all the help I can get.
Okay, this game can use flashing lights.
Alright, I just won't look at it.
Sure, why not?
See, it's easy.
All you need to know is up equals big, down equals small.
Yeah.
Okay, alright, cool.
...for facing massive dilemmas, or for allowing the smallest problems to get blown completely out of proportion.
Dude, what the fuck?
Don't diagnose me.
What?
No, it's a puzzle game.
...and effective dream therapy while you rest in the comfort of our tits, right next to the secondary overflow...
Wait, what?
Really?
Thank you so much for the tier 1, 3, 1 sub.
Woo!
Can you get some break nights for me?
Can I get a free What?
What?
I can't even read the...
Okay, who the fuck reads terms of services anyway?
And no one watches it.
No one reads terms of services anyway.
I just automatically signed it.
So...
Alright...
What's this?
Perception as reality.
Oh!
Oh, how did I shrink it?
How do I shrink it?
OOOHHH!
OH MY GOD!
Oh sh... okay, okay.
Oh... oh, I get it, I get it.
I can still, I can.
I can make it smaller.
Wait, can I jump?
I can make it even smaller.
Like, how small can I make this?
You make things big or small by changing the perspectives.
Oh shit.
Oh my gosh, I'm big!
I'm big too!
My thing zoomed in!
I don't know why my thing... wait, let me fix this.
I don't know why this is fucking up real cool.
I'm fixing my thingy.
I don't know why this is fucking up.
This is weird.
I'm so scoff chat.
I...
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
I went from big to small to big.
Yo, yo it won't let me!
I don't know how big is it!
Okay, fuck it.
It's fine.
I'll just... yo look at this.
Oh hey guys.
Hey.
Hey guys.
You guys are having...
Alright, alright.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Have a butt heart.
Thank you.
Or I could do like this.
Hey.
Whoa, hey.
Look at me.
It's called perception right here.
It's like a... it's really... it's actually interactive.
It's like a...
it's really...
it's actually interactive.
It's like a...
it's really...
it's actually interactive.
Oh my god, Treetop.
Thank you so much for the five gifted subs.
Thank you.
Wait, wait.
Let me zoom back in.
Thank you so much for the five...
Hey.
Thank you Treetop for the five gifted subs.
Gonna get some Bargnights real quick.
For Treetop for the five gifted subs.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Woo!
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Wait.
What was I supposed to do?
I was not... Oh shit.
I was not listening to anything.
Oh wait, wait, wait.
Oh.
Okay, so apparently it takes like...
It takes like two hours to finish this game.
So this is gonna take me like five minutes practically.
Oh, I gotta make the... Wait, finish?
Or how do I make this big?
Big?
Big.
Do I bring this here?
The kuzm is hilarious.
Well...
Here.
I'm stupid.
GrandTek, thank you so much for the thousand bits.
Thank you.
Holy shit, guys.
I didn't even... I don't even know what I'm doing.
I'm so... I'm so tired.
I'm so tired right now.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing right now.
Thank you so much for the thousand...
Oh.
Oh, you're so tiny.
Does far make big?
Or is it close make big?
No, it's far makes big, right?
Far is big.
Far is... far is... I don't know perspective.
Hey, I draw for a living.
I still don't... I still don't know...
Did I fuck up?
Oh, if I look up, it goes big?
Oh!
Oh my god, my brain.
I didn't even... I didn't even read that comment, Chrissy.
I thought about that before... before you said anything.
I didn't need your help.
Okay, maybe... okay.
Look at that.
Look at... look at that.
I'm so... I'm so...
Oh, I can't... what is this?
He said...
Doubt that the stairs... the stairs are fire.
Doubt that the sun don't move.
Doubt...
What?
I don't want...
Is he?
Wait, I didn't listen.
What did he say?
Did I just leave?
Okay, I'll just leave.
I guess I'll just leave.
Oh, wait... wait... what?
What are you doing?
Oh!
That's too big.
Wait...
What the fuck?
Okay, okay, I need to be tinier.
Okay, yo street... wait.
Can I throw it?
Please, please my arms!
Okay,
wait, wait.
It'll work!
Please, please, sir, please!
Why can't I throw it?
There we go.
Wasn't even that hard.
It wasn't even that hard.
Hold right... now I can write.
Rotate?
I am so... dude.
What do I do with this?
What do I need to do with this?
Oh!
Can I make it bigger?
Wait- w-wait, WAIT!
I put it-
Yo, yo, I'm gonna- y'all got this speeder in this game!
Oh I'm dead!
Crunchy thank you so much for gonna give this up!
Hey, I think I'm dead.
I think I'm dead, guys.
Adrien, thank you so much for hiding those rules.
I can't break it for the fall.
How did I break it?
I don't know what.
Okay, wait.
Yo, wait, wait, wait.
Maybe I can make a speedrun.
Speedrun strat.
Alright.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me see if I can do it.
Let me see.
Let me see if I can...
Yeah, see?
I don't break it anymore.
Look.
It's okay.
Oh my god, that's a big ass cheese.
That's a big ass cheese.
Okay.
Can I make it bigger?
Breaking cheese.
Cheese.
I can't break it anymore.
It won't let me break it.
It won't let me break the game anymore.
Wait, how...
Wait, wait, wait.
Why are you small?
This stress...
Wait, why is it so small?
I can't do it.
Did I break it again?
Does it not go big anymore?
I think I broke it again.
It's not going...
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's a big ass cheese.
You're next to the wall, I think.
Alright.
It's not gonna let you cheese it anymore.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Wait, how do I get up?
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
It's not going big.
It doesn't let me go big anymore.
Alright.
Okay, rotate time.
Rotate time.
Am I rotate?
Rotate.
Alright.
Okay.
Here we go.
Please.
Oh my god.
How am I stuck at this cheese level?
Okay, wait.
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
There you go.
I got it.
Hi, Dynamax.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
Have a... have a butt heart.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
It's not gonna let me cheese anymore.
What is this?
1205?
Is it 1205?
I'm a fucking idiot.
It's 1237 AM.
Okay, two.
What can I do here?
Am I stuck?
Oh.
Please, there's...
other door.
Okay.
Open?
A variable degree of force can and will be authorized to ensure patient safety.
Uh, force can...
Wait, if I stay here, does it force me out?
Are you booked the game once?
You think I won't break it again?
Okay, fuck it.
I can't be fucking bothered.
Unless...
What can I do here?
Oh, I thought I could break this.
Oh shit!
Okay, no, that doesn't work.
Drink a soda?
How do I drink a soda?
Oh shit!
Oh.
Can it go bigger?
Oh, bigger.
Bigger.
How big can this soda get?
Did that do anything?
Oh shit.
How big can you get soda?
Oh my god, this is a big ass soda!
I don't know what to do with you.
What am I doing?
I don't know what to do with this.
Okay, I think...
Okay, so now...
It's soda-solid diabetes.
Pouring extreme thirst.
Okay, what...
Oh shit!
Okay, how do I get through here?
Oh, I need tiny soda.
Wait, unless...
That actually worked!
Bring my soda with me.
Tiny plug.
Oh, my soda.
Oh, that's stupid.
I can't bring soda.
Is this a horror game?
What the fuck?
Oh, I'm
gonna die.
Let me get small again.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
I'm making this small.
Okay, wait.
As soon you will see...
Please don't tell me this is a horror game!
I was not...
I'm not...
I'm not prepared for that.
Uh...
Maybe?
Oh, you're so tiny now.
Can I crouch?
Oh, no.
This is...
No, please.
Please.
I can't think here.
What do you want me to do?
Please!
Please get in here!
What's that body?
No!
Please.
Just make small and put...
You made a...
Okay, is there another hole?
Here?
Okay, not here.
Maybe...
Okay, maybe...
Oh.
Why would you let me put the button earlier?
Dude, I'm just like...
I'm just reinforcing it.
I'm re-forcing everything until it works!
This game is like, Layers of Fear.
I want you to accept that I play it and I trick you down to Episode 3 of Nightmares for a week.
Episode 3 of Nightmares for a week.
Oh, it should even be hot in here!
Oh?
Well...
What?
It's for just a size.
It's a relative object.
It's put a gift card.
You're using words I don't... you're using too many... too many big words for me right now.
How do I get this in here?
Dude, I'm an artist too.
And I don't know shit about perspective.
What the fuck?
Let me in!
This is open.
What is...
What?
Hello?
Oh my god, dude, my...
God, please!
Come over!
I'm so fucking confused!
Please!
Give me the block!
Okay.
Maybe if I bring it here?
Okay, no.
Okay, wait, unless...
Wait!
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
God, I'm so fucking sorry.
Is this the only game we've been seeing?
I was reading chat!
I just didn't understand what the fuck you're talking about!
I just...
I didn't know what... I was like, over the...
Over?
You stupid?
There's a window!
How am I gonna put it over?
There's a fucking window!
I was thinking, damn, my chat is so fucking stupid.
Can't believe they don't know that...
That there's a window here and objects can't go through windows.
God.
Oh my gosh, I think I'm lost now.
Where am I?
Wait, what is there a...
Wait.
Oh, wait a minute.
Oh, wait, I'm back here.
I'm so close to murder right now.
It hurts.
What are you guys talking about?
Am I stuck?
No.
Alright.
Yo, I'm so sorry.
I'm so good.
And...
I don't know how I got here.
Huh?
Where's that opening?
What?
Is Mabel turning on the braidsaw?
It is pretty.
It's pretty.
How big can I make this?
Do you think I can break the game again?
Okay, I need to get it so it's on both sides.
It was still...
No, I gotta make this bigger.
Okay.
And then bigger.
We need to use our noggins no matter what.
No matter how stupid we are.
Press the fire.
Can I take the... Press the fire.
There's fire alarms here?
...light recognition on your completion of the sign-up.
Jericho!
Thank you so much for the four gifted songs!
Woo!
Can we get some break nights real quick for Jericho?
Thank you, thank you, thank you guys.
Holy shit, thank you.
I am so fucking tired.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm not listening to this girl talk.
I don't... Oh, gosh.
Thank you so much for the follow, Edward.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a... Have a have a butt heart.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Huh?
Oh, cheese.
Wait, where the fuck did cheese come from?
Where did you come from?
I'll just say enjoy this while putting together my account by anger.
What do you mean you're angry?
What the fuck do you mean?
Okay.
Oh!
Did I break it?
Wait, wait, wait.
I got it.
Okay, no.
I don't got this.
Here?
Okay.
It's simple.
I'm angry.
Okay.
Oh.
Wait.
Oh!
Why do you laugh so much though?
What do you mean?
But why wouldn't you rotate it?
Like...
Okay, and then I...
Okay, no.
That's not it.
Wait, do I...
But you seem like so happy or something.
I'm laughing out pain.
No, I'm not.
I'm actually... I'm actually so fucking depressed that laughing is the only way to get the pain out.
Why does it keep going small?
What the fuck?
What the... Please!
What the fuck am I gonna do with this?
Oh, sh... Oh.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Okay, I mean, that works.
Just get angry and it'll work, I guess.
Before someone's gonna get...
I don't know what I did.
I just... It's okay.
I never... I don't know what I'm doing.
If you don't know, just be angry, I guess.
Now where the fuck do I go?
Okay.
She just makes it bigger.
She just makes...
Oh!
Did I win?
Just one more round and something happens.
Exactly.
I don't need to figure out shit out.
I don't need to use my brain.
All I have to do is just...
We won!
Woo!
Anyway, that was a great stream chat.
Wow, I had a great stream.
I'm so happy.
Crunchy!
Thank you so much!
This just came through.
Thank you so much, Crunchy, for the tier one.
Two months in a row.
Woo!
Can I get some break nights real quick for Crunchy?
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
How long do you think the stream will last?
What do you mean?
It's a ten minute stream.
This game is two hours long, so it's practically ten minutes.
All right, where do I go now?
Game soda.
Oh shit!
Wait, I can have more than two now.
If I can achieve...
What the fuck?
Okay, fire alarm?
Where's the fire alarm?
Where is it?
Where's the fi... Oh!
Is that it?
Oh, cool.
That's it!
Apparently, I can get an achievement if I...
Oh!
Oh, is it broken?
Oh, shit!
Fucking... God!
Can I grab anything else?
The funbots almost makes it worth it.
Can I open doors?
Is how to lose brain cells?
What am I gonna do with this?
Okay, it tries to make something bigger.
It's like, boy!
Get bigger!
Okay.
I'm gonna make it big.
All right.
Does it get bigger?
Go big!
Big.
Okay, it's stuck.
It's stuck on this one size.
Oh!
It's doing it again.
So, okay.
Come on!
Where's my tiny?
Perspective...
Thank you so much for the...
What?
What the fuck?
Who was that?
Oh, my God.
Oh my god this game is giving me jumpscares.
Thank you again, Cripple, for the $20.
Thank you guys.
I really do appreciate it.
I'm lost.
There's only one- wait.
Look at the baby door.
Wait!
Oh, I know what to do!
Wait.
I'm gonna make it small.
Alright, baby door.
I wanted to put it- okay, I guess that wasn't the answer.
Baby door was not the answer.
Alright.
Oh my god, go tiny doors!
Look at this door for ants.
Look at baby door.
Baby door.
Can I make it tinier?
Oh, why did I make it tinier?
Oh.
Okay.
Look at the baby door.
Baby door.
Holy fuck, you know I'm tired when I'm just fucking making baby doors.
Exit temporarily.
Move.
Don't talk to me on my baby door again!
Baby door.
Baby is door.
Holy shit, this is like- this is like fucking sleep deprived humor right now, chat.
You know what?
Sleep deprivation humor, am I right?
Who the fuck am I?
TKK, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a- have a- have a fun heart.
Thank you so much.
What the fuck?
What is that?
You wanna- Michael Strieber laughs at door.
Oh, that's trippy.
That is so trippy.
This is really tripping me out.
Yo, I did it.
That- well, that was really fucking trippy though.
Wait, do I go up here?
You missed too far.
Oh, oh.
What the fuck?
What was that sound?
Michael laughs at door.
Oh.
I'm tripping.
I'm not even on this on.
Dude, that was- alright.
Okay, big.
Alright.
And then I do like this?
How do I rotate?
Oh.
Okay, maybe I'll make it bigger.
Okay.
Pee-pee-ma still creeps me out even though we're past the- the streets.
Pee-pee-ma has a cam- pee-pee- No, don't you fucking dare, Midnight.
Don't you fucking dare.
Crimble, thank you again for the- for another donation.
Thank you, Crimble.
I really appreciate it, guys.
Oh.
Okay, I think this was too big.
I think maybe I made it too big.
Michael laughs at door.
Who the fuck?
I have a- I have a butthurt.
Thank you.
Michael laughs at door.
What the fuck?
Now it's back to jazz?
Back to piano?
Michael laughs at door.
What the fuck?
I didn't even see.
What?
I don't even know what was supposed to be scary.
Michael laughs at door.
What?
What was it?
Michael laughs at door.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
Michael laughs at door.
What the fuck?
Every time I go up, it changes.
Michael laughs at door.
Oh.
Okay, stair con.
Michael laughs
at door.
Where am I supposed to go?
Michael laughs at door.
It really shows what music can do for your mood, right?
Now it's just fucking terrifying.
Yeah.
Michael laughs at door.
Oh.
Okay.
Can't bring it.
Michael laughs at door.
Wait, why is it tiny?
I should just sleep deprived for this.
Michael laughs at door.
Yo, me too.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Why are you tiny?
Michael
laughs at door.
Let me just keep...
Okay.
Michael laughs at door.
Oh.
No, I don't like this.
I don't like how it's being spooky.
I'm not even mentioning something too big or too tiny.
Okay.
Is this supposed to be...
I'm like, oh this is a very chill and relaxing, very fun puzzle game.
It deals with optical illusions.
Where did you come from?
Where did this come from?
Okay, I'll take it.
You hit the perspective and I'm just not looking.
Where did it go?
Didn't even need to try.
Okay.
Dude, I don't think I'm solving this puzzle, these puzzles, the right way.
I honestly think I'm just fucking around and in the puzzle game, we're like, oh that man, she's so smart.
She instantly figured it out.
But no, I'm not even fucking looking at it and they're like...
Looked out for a second and it turns tiny.
Oh, like this?
Oh, it was this.
Oh, so I wasn't even looking.
Where's the flower?
Okay, wait.
Okay, flower.
Flower?
I'm so confused.
Flower.
Do I leave?
Okay.
Hi, Eclipse.
Hello.
Another one.
Thank you again for the five dollars, Crimbo.
Thank you.
What's this?
I'm so confused.
Maybe if I move around.
Maybe here.
Maybe the game will feel bad for me.
What's that?
I'm sorry.
What was that?
Where was that sound from?
Okay, maybe...
Maybe...
What?
I don't know.
I don't know where that came from.
I didn't know.
Did you know?
What's this?
What's going on?
What am I supposed to do?
Oh.
Oh my gosh, I'm so smart.
Ta-da!
How do I make this big?
You got your cute little dino?
How do you get a cute dino badge?
I have too many badges though.
Wait, why did it get small?
Crample!
Thank you, Crample!
Thank you for the five!
Thank you, I really appreciate all the donations.
Thank you so much.
How do I get a...
Where did that cute coming from?
Where is that coming from?
Go to the Twitch and type the email.
Refresh your page.
Go to Dente.
Next to the... Just go to Twitch.
Oh, okay.
That's so much work.
That's so much work though.
I say it as I'm struggling to make... Can I bring this over?
Alright, exit.
Oh, I can do this.
Okay, wait.
I can do this.
Oh, wait.
I can do...
I can do this.
My perception is reality.
Alright.
Like this?
Am I doing it?
Okay, I don't think I'm doing it.
Maybe I was on the other side.
Oh, that... I just platforming easy.
I'm fucking... I'm the worst at platforming games.
I'm actually one of the worst platform... Like, I'm so bad at platformers.
What the fuck do you want me to do?
Wait.
Oh.
Oh!
I know, I know, I know, I know.
My brain, my brain is... My brain is analyzing.
My brain... I go up.
I go up.
And then I do... And then I do this, right?
And... Holy shit, I'm so fucking smart.
Okay, I need... I need...
It needs to be bigger.
Okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
It needs to be bigger.
It needs to be... Why is it not getting bigger?
Okay, okay.
And then...
And then... Okay, I made it small.
Okay, I made it small.
I accidentally made it...
Made it... Made it small.
Okay, and then...
And I do this, right?
And then... And then...
And then... I think I'm not... I don't think this is the right answer.
I don't think I'm doing it right.
For some...
For some reason, I might not be doing this right.
Oh my god, Crimble.
Another five dollars.
Thank you, Crimble.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for the donations.
You didn't have to.
I really appreciate it.
Okay, I'm so confused.
I am so fucking confused.
Okay, perception is reality.
Okay.
Wait.
You gotta make the door?
How the fuck do you make a door?
Look at it!
Okay.
Okay, maybe...
You gotta make the door.
Can I take the paintings out?
You're still gonna make the doors and the mountain?
Oh my crap.
Okay, maybe if I...
What?
How are you guys doing that?
I know it's you guys.
Look, the other times, I would've been like, oh maybe it's my game fucking up.
But you guys are fucking... the gruh...
ah sound.
Now I know you guys are fucking with me.
You guys are fucking with me.
Miss, are you okay?
Oh my god.
It's the donations, isn't it?
It's the fucking donations.
Maybe if I make this big?
Oh my god.
I'm getting like mini jump scares too by it.
Okay, maybe if I keep making it big.
Maybe.
Wait, maybe.
Wait, wait, wait.
I get it.
Oh!
You're right.
Wait, no.
Wait.
What the fuck am I doing?
Okay.
Wait.
If I jump, maybe?
Just gotta jump?
Okay, wait.
No, that's not it.
Okay.
Maybe.
Oh, maybe it's this side.
Right?
Okay, it's definitely not this side.
It's definitely not this side.
I don't know.
Okay, maybe if I do this, I'll just keep making it big.
Right?
All I do to do is just make it big.
And then... and then I...
I go this like this?
Like... look at the pillars.
What do you mean look... oh!
Wait.
Oh!
Okay.
I did it!
I figured it out, Grimble!
How was I supposed to know there was something there?
CrispyBoy had enough.
CrispyBoy was like this bitch.
I can't deal with this bitch anymore.
Oh, BabyDoor.
Oh.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, that's so...
This game was marked on one of the top 5 scary...
BabyDoor.
CrispyBoy had enough.
He had enough with my bullshit.
Now you got BabyDoor.
Oh.
I hate this.
I hate how the music just changes like this.
Oh.
Well.
Okay.
Are you lucid dreaming?
Have you had to the exit to wake up?
Uh-huh.
BabyDoor.
Is that it?
Oh, okay.
All he just said was I'm fucking lost.
Thank you.
Thank you for your input.
I really do appreciate it.
Button?
I didn't...
I didn't know we'd get lost.
There's only one door.
It's not supposed to be a...
What do you mean, Jericho?
It's only been 5 minutes since that's passed.
Oh, that's...
What's that?
Is that person looking at me?
Oh, no.
It's this.
I was like, that looks like a person right here.
It's just this.
Oh?
Oh, no.
I have to be up top.
Uh...
Oh, what do you want me to do?
Okay.
Something would let me pick up, right?
Oh.
Block!
Block?
Oh.
Yes.
And then I just make it big.
Okay.
Big time.
And then...
Also, can you...
You can collect the chess pieces?
Why the fuck... I'm not gonna play this game ever again after.
What do I need chess pieces for?
Put it...
You're so smart.
Thank you.
I know.
Chess.
It's just the penis shows.
Okay.
And this.
Oh.
Now they beat the Doki stream and mac and cheese at one.
Dude, I actually had mac and cheese today, too.
I had it for lunch and dinner.
Baby door!
Oh.
I can't open baby door.
Yeah.
I just... It's cause I couldn't finish...
I couldn't finish it for lunch, so I just had it.
Okay.
I actually...
Uh-huh.
Oh.
Okay.
I actually...
Oh, I lost my train of thought.
Oh!
I woke up...
I woke up... I slept...
Oh my gosh.
Please, Glenn.
Dr. Glenn.
I can't fucking talk with you.
You're very ASMR voice.
I'm fucking losing my train of thought right now.
I like this factory hella aesthetic.
So, I actually went to bed.
Um...
I went to bed at...
11 AM.
I woke up...
I woke up at 3.30 PM.
And here we are.
That's why my brain is not functioning very well right now.
Alright.
Where do we go?
Okay.
If I grab everything, something will happen, right?
Oh, you're in the content you make.
It's hilarious and so fun, but it's hurting my head.
I'm not sure I can take part of this too many.
Like I said, I love you, but your intelligence is physically hurting.
What do you mean?
Okay.
Look.
I'm so tired.
You know?
This is not fully the fault of my brain.
It's also the fault of fucking tired.
Look.
I swear.
I'm a bit smarter.
Just a tiny bit smarter than this.
I swear.
I swear, guys.
Can't make that...
Maybe if I spam everything, something will let me pick it up.
Paid actor.
Okay.
Something would let me pick it up, right?
Right, guys?
Can I pick up the moon?
Oh, I can pick up the moon!
Yo, what the fuck?
Yo, what the fuck is on the moon?
Yo, it's tiny cheese!
Wait, what's this?
Oh my god, it's a baby door!
Oh, dude!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, my mind is so blown right now.
Oh my god!
Look at this!
My brain just...
Can I make this bigger?
I wanna make big.
I want big.
Nasa did tell us about this!
Baby door!
What the... oh, wait.
Wait, how tiny can I make this?
Oh my god!
Look at this!
Look at how tiny I can make this.
Dude, I fucking love how you can make this so fucking tiny.
Look at that.
Chucky, lose the door!
Fly me to the moon, but not like that!
Omega baby door!
Hello, my name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
In the event that this elevator does not wake you up, In the event that this elevator does not wake you up, don't interact with anything that strikes you as psychologically...
Okay, you're so tired of what you're yelling and laughing at while you're taking baby doors or talking.
Have you never met someone that was so fucking tired that they're so dirty and delusional now?
If you see a bear in a zoo, please push them in the crease as hard as you can and immediately blow it.
As there's no brain cells yet.
No fucking brain cells right now.
It was until adopted eventually.
Are you expecting more from me?
You're not a true fan.
Alright, wait, where's baby door?
Wait, where's the baby door?
Oh, there's baby door.
Alright, baby door.
It's time to be big boy.
It's time to be big door now.
Time to be big door.
Alright, baby door.
Stop.
Ho ho.
Are you bringing the moon with me?
Oh.
Dude, every time the music changes, it fucks with me so much.
How big can I make the moon?
Oh, can I make the moon tiny?
Oh, look at that.
It's like a golf ball.
I'm gonna put this moon right here.
It's a new moon.
Wait, wait, wait, no!
Let me think!
Oh, look at that.
I'm gonna bring the moon with me.
Jimbo Lishy!
Oh my gosh, this is...
Whoa, Fatal D!
What the fuck?
Nani Mare!
Oh my gosh, dude, there's so many of you guys.
Holy shit!
Thank you so much for all the follows.
Oh my gosh!
They're just so...
getting lit.
Like, what is this?
What is all of this?
Thank you all!
Oh my gosh, there's so many follows.
I'm the last...
lit voice.
Dude, I don't fucking know.
Did you solve the...
You were the last...
I'm the last...
Oh, I need to close the top.
We're corrupting you with licks.
Is it truly corruption if you like licks, though?
Is it truly corruption?
Thank you...
Holy shit, there's so many of you.
Thank you for all the follows.
I can't even read it properly.
He needs to sleep, but you're too cute.
Thank you, thank you.
Dude, I don't even know if this is spam.
I don't even know if someone is just fucking spam follows.
Alright, I need...
Oh.
Okay, okay, oh.
Thank you, thank you for all the follows.
I really do.
These are bots.
Dude, I don't even know if they're...
We're not boots.
Okay.
You know what?
Bots wouldn't be able to...
Bots wouldn't be able to fuck up their spelling.
So I believe you're right.
You're right.
I feel like AIs have progressed enough to be able to spell check.
So, I feel like we're not...
But, yeah.
Thank you.
We're not bots.
We're not...
Thank you for all the follows, guys.
Thank you.
Have some hearts.
Have some blood hearts.
Thank you.
Goodnight.
Goodnight, everyone.
Yo, wait.
Was I just here?
Wait.
The color changed.
It's not red anymore.
BBC is gonna...
Alright, goodnight everyone.
I guess it's PP stream, right?
Goodnight, everyone.
Coming from...
BFee stream.
Thank you for...
Thank you for coming over.
And for all these follows.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank...
Oh, nice music time.
Nice music time.
I don't have...
I love every second of it.
Wait.
Okay, I don't...
Your decisions imply a failure of orientation, which reflects negatively on the standard orientation protocol.
Alright, it's nice music time.
You will rectify this failure immediately.
I'll rectify...
Oh, nice.
We're wholesome to wholesome being talkative.
This is philosophy.
That philosophy to live by.
Hello, TD.
Hello, hello.
I forgot dinner.
I should... Yeah, you should totally eat.
Like I said, I only had like...
You asked me like what I...
What I had for...
What I had...
Can I keep it getting bigger?
Where did it go?
Okay.
Okay, I made it too big.
I might have made it too big.
So this is a self-read from Fifi.
Who's Fifi?
Is Fifi... Okay, I'm gonna assume that Fifi is a streamer.
Okay, we all know Fifi has to be a streamer if I'm getting like...
Fifi is a B2B streamer.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I'm just so...
I'm fucking... I'm sorry.
My brain isn't working very well right now.
My brain...
I had four hours of sleep and I'm trying to figure this shit out.
But thank you, Fifi.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you, Fifi for...
Oh.
Stop.
Okay, so I have to make a staircase here.
I have to make a staircase.
And then...
I have to make a bunch of other...
Well, I'm not used to sleeping this little.
I think... I slept at like...
10... 11 AM.
11...
11 AM to...
I used to... I... Oh my god.
I can't even form sentences.
I'm used to getting like...
7 to 8 hours of sleep.
So I'm trying to...
So like I slept at like...
11 AM today and woke up at like 3.30 PM.
So I'm so... I'm not used to it.
I am not.
I'm so not used to like sleeping that little.
It's been like...
Whoa!
What are you?
Oh!
Whoa!
I don't like this!
I don't... Yo!
What the fuck is a tag?
There's supposed to be holes... very...
Oh, it's just a relaxing puzzle game.
A real... Not enough for me to go into a fucking basement.
Beeping metal where...
And it takes you to a fucking basement after.
What?
Professional tip.
The average adult can only withstand 3 to 5 dreams per night.
Once this threshold is eclipsed by entering more dreams, your mind will suffer an explosive mental overload.
This is not good.
Reorienting you for the emergency exit protocol.
Okay, just making sure y'all understand I mean no harm.
Just a...
Joke.
Well, kind of.
Dude, I...
Zeno, wait.
What did you say?
I don't even remember what you just said.
So, I...
I...
I appreciate...
Wait, no.
You apologize to Jericho.
Okay, Jericho.
We're just joking.
Okay, dude.
I don't even know what we're talking about anymore.
I'm just out here trying to...
Trying to make sure I remember what I'm doing.
Okay,
dice.
Dice?
Dice.
Chris, really happy to see you as always.
Have fun and hang out.
Oh, thank you, Necessity.
Are you heading to bed right now, Necessity?
Hey, Gerard, thank you for hanging out with us.
I always do appreciate it.
I think we were talking about embarrassing things that happened in elementary school.
Oh, I cannot...
What?
Oh, wait.
Puzzle.
Puzzle?
And then...
Oh, wait.
What the fuck is this for then?
Wait, what?
What?
Oh, are we done?
Oh, it's finally the follows are done.
Alright.
Then what do we do with this?
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, thank you so much for the follows.
Thank you.
Oh, everyone.
Dude, there's so many.
I can't...
I can't read all your names.
I'm so sorry.
But thank you everyone for the follows.
I really, really do appreciate it.
Appreciate it, guys.
Have a blood heart.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
Oh.
Okay.
Um.
Alright.
It's just... we build.
We just gotta build.
Right?
Oh.
Okay.
I do this.
And then...
Okay.
I do...
No.
Wait.
I do...
Oh, shit.
There we go.
See?
I knew it.
It's not just that it's not 200 people.
It could be just shadowing to you.
Oh, no, no.
I know.
I was saying... my notifications went by so fast.
I couldn't think...
I can't think all of you.
But I really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Crispy.
Why are you so mean?
I'm sorry.
I'm fucking sorry.
I don't know what I'm doing right now.
Oh.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh.
My god.
My dog fucking jumpscared me.
Jokey.
What are you doing?
Oh.
He's looking at himself.
Sorry.
My dog is looking at himself and thinks it's a...
Uh.
My dog was looking at himself in the mirror and he's like Yo.
Who is this?
Who is this guy?
Jokey attack.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
This doesn't scare me anymore.
Yeah.
He's like...
He saw his own reflection and he was like, who is he?
Who is this bitch right here?
He's looking at me right now.
Okay.
What time is it now?
It is 5 AM.
Oh my god.
That's a lot of dogs.
Okay.
Oh.
Wait.
Please.
I'm sorry.
Wait.
No.
I'm going back into the light.
Oh.
No.
I'm sorry.
I'm going back into the light.
I'm so sorry.
Jokey.
What the fuck was that?
What?
What was that?
Okay.
I won't look again.
Jokey.
Fear.
Oh.
I'm never relaxing.
I was lucky.
Oh my god.
I have a can of soda.
I was talking about a joke I made about a mouse.
Stupidity.
Um.
I really do appreciate you.
I just want to make sure you understand why I mean no harm.
Okay.
That's okay.
Oh.
I don't like that.
Why are we in the freezer locker?
Why are we...
Why are we in the locker now?
How is this my fucking...
Okay.
No.
You said sorry.
I said sorry.
Murder!
What?
Can I die in this game?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute here.
That actually got...
Tricked into playing a scary game chat.
Why the fuck does it say murder?
Alright.
I don't think I like it here anymore.
Suddenly we have a piece.
Just don't die.
Oh shit.
Oh I got an optical illusion myself out of here.
Wow.
Doors are locked too.
Bro it's the weekly murder session.
How did you know about...
How did you not know about this shit in my head?
Well then.
You know he's here.
How the fuck do I get out of here now?
Okay.
Oh is it?
Oh.
Wait.
Where am I?
Oh.
What's this?
That's one of the scariest brains in the northern hemisphere.
Okie monkey.
Oh die.
Die?
Die.
Oh dokey.
Why is my dog trying to scare me too?
Okay.
Oh.
Ah.
I see.
Wait did you actually.
Wait Acer did you.
Acer did you know it?
Did you.
Did you make that up?
And then it was actually right?
Oh.
I don't think that's diet soda.
I don't think that's diet soda guys.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Let's kill her.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Did I got.
Oh.
I got tricked into a scary game.
A drill has a good spidery.
Oh thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Have a blood heart.
I.
Oh.
Does this also say.
Oh it's hey it's bean sundae.
Oh.
Oh man.
Where did this blood go?
Oh.
Remember when I was in a children's hospital.
In a red brain trial.
Doki shh.
No.
Sorry my dog.
Doki no.
Come on.
No.
Sorry.
He's scared too.
He saw the blood and he didn't like it as well.
Uh.
Maybe if I go this way.
And then.
Nope that didn't work.
Maybe if I.
Well.
Oh.
I'm never gonna play more games again.
Where the fuck do I go?
Okay so he was barking.
The reason why he was barking.
Was.
So I figured out why my dog was barking.
It was because he got his leg stuck.
Stuck.
Yeah.
So we gave him like a.
We got him.
We gave him like a.
Um.
Like a shirt.
As like a blanket.
Like an old shirt.
And he got his paw stuck in one of the shirt holes.
So he was like please help me.
We just keep falling down.
I'm just gonna.
Maybe if I keep falling down.
I would.
Maybe if I just keep falling down.
He'll.
Okay maybe that isn't it.
Maybe that was not it.
You know.
Sometimes falling down works.
Huh?
I'm gonna go back.
I don't like looking up top chat.
I don't think I like it.
I didn't find the finish.
It has worked before in the past.
It'll work again.
Right?
Where the fuck do I go?
Where else do I go?
Maybe if I.
Maybe if I do this?
Okay no.
Um.
Maybe if I jump?
I told you.
If I kept doing the same thing.
Over and over.
It would work.
If you thought I was stupid.
Okay.
Maybe.
Okay maybe.
Okay.
It was a fucking maze.
You proof forced it.
Wait okay.
Are you still insane now?
It's gonna.
Alright goodnight Victor.
Thanks for hanging out with us.
I really do appreciate.
Okay.
Alright now.
Now I just need to jump over here.
Right?
Wait no.
Okay.
I told you.
All I have to do.
Is just.
I told you chat.
I don't need a.
Oh I don't like this.
I don't like this.
I can't.
Man.
What do you have to say?
Dr. Glenn Pierce.
And I'd like to talk more about the feelings of.
Worthlessness and sadness.
Oh come on.
I'm already sad enough.
You feel this way.
Because you won't.
Turn your volume down for this next part.
You see all around you.
Excuse me.
And that's exactly why we're here to help.
What?
Yo.
If you're here to help.
Like.
I don't.
Listen don't touch the button.
Don't touch the.
Murder is just.
Man.
I thought it was going to be a nice.
Prospect game about solving.
But I'm so tired.
I didn't think I was going to be doing a puzzle game.
That.
That turns into a horror game.
This is going to be.
You picked up.
A leaking item.
And then chopped it.
Oh man.
Murder is just perspective.
Who would have thought.
Damn.
Murdering people is just a matter of perspective.
Maybe if I just don't look at it.
If I do this.
Okay that makes me more scared.
Actually.
You know what.
You know.
Oh my god.
Maybe if I close my eyes.
What if I chat.
What if I just close my eyes.
Just explain to me.
I'm just going to look at chat.
And then you guys can tell me what's going on.
What happened.
Oh I don't like this.
I don't.
I don't like this.
Yo.
I just.
Holy shit.
I fucking hate this chat.
Oh hey there's more blood.
Hey look.
What happened.
Dude I'm missing the baby doors guys.
I really miss the baby doors.
I really miss our baby door adventure.
Our chats are always cursing.
It's amazing.
Oh is that a person.
On the window.
Right now.
Who are you sir.
Who are you.
Oh
hey there bro.
Hey.
Oh yo hey.
Oh there's no window.
Oh Crimbo.
Don't you fucking dare.
Crimbo.
Crimbo thank you for the five dollars.
Oh.
Oh man I'm just gonna.
I'm just gonna wait.
Crimbo I'm waiting until this plays Crimbo.
Now I hate Saturdays.
Hey there sir.
Hey there.
Hey.
Oh it's.
Oh.
I see.
Ah.
So that's who's doing all the murdering tonight.
Watch out in attack.
Diagonally.
Now I'm a little sad.
Now I got someone wholesome.
Oh I don't know about that.
I don't know if I'm actually wholesome.
I don't think so.
Well it's just.
I am not that wholesome.
I'm very sorry.
Oh.
Alright back.
Hey look there's more blood.
There's more blood.
Oh.
Hey.
Thanks for closing the door.
Thank you.
Oh that's cool.
Oh.
It's dark now.
Wow.
Chess pieces.
Okay.
Where's more blood.
Hahaha.
Let's chat some.
Some diet.
Some yourself.
Additional dreams.
Is this Freddy now?
What is this?
Am I fighting Freddy now?
Hahaha.
Are you kidding me.
Oh shit look it's fucking.
Hahaha.
Nightmare.
It's nightmare on elm street time.
Hahaha.
I missed my baby doors guys.
How do I get out?
Okay.
Is that how my room looks right now?
It's weird.
Okay I don't like this.
How do I even get out?
Yo please.
Just like please.
I don't know.
What exit sign?
What do you mean exit sign?
Oh.
Exit sign?
What do you mean the red glowy thing?
Oh.
The red glowy thing.
Hahaha.
Oh.
Okay maybe I should make it big.
Okay and then.
I do.
Okay.
What do you do with you?
Hey there.
Hey there buddy.
Look at me it's already big.
It is so.
What do you mean?
Look at how big this is.
Look at walls.
I'm looking.
I'm looking respectfully.
I'm looking respectfully right now.
Can I bring him out here?
Okay.
Hey there guys.
Hey there.
Hahaha.
Oh that's pretty.
That's a big one.
Yo I don't like this.
Oh my god I hate this.
Hahaha.
I'm gonna make it bigger.
Fuck it.
Dude remember when we were making baby doors?
I missed that.
I missed the baby door times.
I really make it.
I miss the baby door times.
Hahaha.
What the fuck does that want me to do?
Okay.
Where are you?
There's no place to bring.
There is.
There is no place to bring a baby door.
Okay.
If I keep clicking on everything.
Something will let me pick it up.
It will let me pick it up.
If I just keep clicking.
Oh.
Whoops.
Oh no I made it small again.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay I made it small again.
Wait.
Wait I keep making it small.
Hahaha.
Okay there we go.
Okay I made it small again.
Hahaha.
There we go.
Now I stopped making it small.
I stopped making it small.
Okay.
Alright.
If I keep clicking.
It will let me pick it up.
Okay maybe.
Maybe that ain't it.
Maybe if I go here instead.
No no.
Maybe if I go through the hole.
Maybe if I'm breaking the gate hole.
Okay.
I don't like this place.
I don't like it here.
Hahaha.
Hey this looks like a good place for murder.
Like a fun place for murder.
Look at how you can hide a body here.
Hahaha.
Damn.
Wowee.
Hahaha.
This is a safe place to bring a baby door.
Those are books for storage.
Oh hey.
Soda.
Whoa soda.
Hahaha.
As long as I have a soda can.
Can't hurt me.
Oh hey there buddy.
Hey there.
Oh please let me bring my soda at least.
Okay.
Can't even bring a fucking soda.
Oh why is it so dark.
Hahaha.
Why is that so dark.
Oh that's cool.
You're adorable.
Hahaha.
Thank you.
Hey.
Where did it go?
Oh did I...
Did I lost it?
Oh I fucked up.
Oh it's tiny.
What the fuck.
How did
it...
Hey there guys.
Hey.
Alright.
Time.
Woooo.
I'm tall.
Oh okay.
I don't know what the fuck that was for.
But okay.
Hahaha.
Yay I get to be tall.
Now what do I do?
Hahaha.
Alright.
Clearly that was not the answer.
Let me make it bigger.
Oh.
Hahaha.
Dork!
Oh.
Nice.
Haha.
Hahaha.
You can also have all of the other but most used objects on a high shelf.
Oh no.
Where did you go?
Wait!
What the fuck?
I just clicked...
Oh...
Where did the knife go?
Oh no!
I don't like that!
Oh look, hey there's a hand print.
Oh look!
There's a hand print!
Damn!
You spilled a lot of paint there!
You spilled a lot of paint.
Oh hey!
Where is this blood trail?
Damn!
Dude, how much blood does this person have?
How much blood does this person have?
This person had a lot of blood, that's for sure.
Ikea?
Idea.
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh man.
No.
I got a sleep tight Mabel took out for me.
Alright, fuck it.
Thank you so much for coming to the stream.
I always do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you have a good night's rest.
Oh, it was paint.
It was fucking paint.
I'm fucking this game.
This game is fucking with me.
Cloud insert projections.
I guess it was paint all along.
Fucking stupid.
I can't believe you guys were so scared of paint.
I can't believe...
Damn, I can't believe y'all were so scared of paint, chat.
Wow.
You will be quizzed to take notes.
Oh, that's a lot of alarms, that's a lot of alarms.
Okay, I feel like you can shut all these alarms down.
And we can smell it a little bit different.
The queen of doors scared us.
What do you mean?
What?
I have no idea what you're talking about.
I have no idea what you're talking about, chat.
We'll find out.
Don't lie in my stream guys.
Hey Fez!
Soda.
Open?
Oh!
Baby door!
Wait, let me make a baby door.
Baby door.
You guys hear my elevator door?
You guys guess she's still a boomer?
Wait, how does that make me a boomer?
How does that even make me a boomer?
Baby door.
Baby door returns.
I'm having a good time.
I keep making doors?
Oh my god, how many doors can I make?
Before I break the game.
I'm having a good time.
I don't know about you guys, I'm having a good time.
Look at this pile of doors.
Holy shit.
Oh.
What are you doing?
I actually...
Damn.
Wow, those are all... this is the most doors I can make apparently.
Even the game told me to fuck off.
The game told me to fuck off.
Wait.
Dude, I can't believe the game told me that.
Dude, that would... you had to know.
A Minecraft flashback.
Is this a puzzle game?
Yeah, it is.
It is.
It is a puzzle game.
It's like an optical illusion.
Um... an optical illusion.
Right click to...
Oh.
I wanna do a lip-sync of this.
Okay, I just need to keep making a thing.
Oh, I don't like this.
Please!
Oh no.
Oh god.
I fucked up.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
Please.
Okay, I just need to...
I just need to...
put it...
Like, keep it.
We are building.
My brother lives near... oh no that's really bad.
You have to get yourself tested or quarantine yourself.
Okay maybe...
I just need to keep making...
That's the last thing I see after watching the horror movie Oculus.
What is Oculus?
What was it about?
Please, please put Pall of Clocks.
Please Pall of Clocks.
My Pall of Clocks.
Please.
I think I made too many.
Okay I think I made too many clocks.
Okay if I keep...
Okay here we go.
Here we go look at that.
My Pall of Clocks worked.
I didn't need to make a big clock.
I'll just make many clocks.
Apple.
Right click to return.
I don't think I should be right clicking.
Apple.
It can't be forever.
There's no way.
Oh.
Wait, wait if I push it.
You can't be there forever.
It
won't stop.
I'm just...
I'm just gonna get it to stop.
It can't be there forever.
Right?
What do you mean Kyle?
I'm just trying to push this off.
What do you want me to do?
How else do you push it off?
Animate thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Hello.
Hello, my heart.
Thank you.
Okay.
Did I fuck up?
I think I fucked...
Oh.
I might have fucked up.
I might have...
Whoa.
Okay.
No.
No, I can push it off.
Don't worry.
I can push it off.
Oh, that's a big apple.
How did I make a big...
Wait.
Oh.
Whoa.
What happened?
What the fuck?
I'm accidentally breaking.
I told you.
If I made enough apples, I would break the game.
I think I actually accidentally broke the puzzle.
I make too many apples.
I can't even tell what's the tentacle.
I can't believe I actually broke it.
I feel like I'm watching art in motion.
What do I do with all these apples?
Oh
look at the baby apples!
Oh my god what the fuck did I make a big apple?
Thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you!
I'm a butthurt!
Thank you so much!
Look at all these apples I can make.
Oh my god look at all these apples.
Why is there a person who creates so many apples?
Oh no!
I
almost got pushed off by the apples!
Oh did I have to get it here?
How did I get here?
Oh!
Oh I get it!
I get it!
I got it.
I keep making apples right?
Wait... did that apple just disappear?
Yellow?
Orange?
Why do I have oranges now?
LazyCaven sorry!
I don't know what you want me to do!
I'm just making apples!
Okay if I keep making apples it'll work.
Right?
All I have to do is keep...
Yo!
Wait!
Why are the apples changing colors?
What do you mean just go upstairs?
Neon apples for the win!
What do you want me to do?
I can't even go through this door!
I gotta keep making apples!
Don't come to me!
Look at all these apples.
And your stream is literally chaotic and neutral.
I keep making apples and one of them will get to me.
Oh my god dude what the fuck.
It's like slamming into...
It's like slamming into the wall now.
Okay.
Alright.
I'll figure this out.
I just need this apple to come closer.
Alright apple.
It's okay.
Just keep... keep going.
Just keep... keep going apple.
Oh I can't...
Oh I maxed out.
I made too many apples.
I actually made too many apples that I can't make anymore.
How is that possible?
I actually made too many.
What do you mean bad?
What do you want me to do with this?
Maybe I just need to beg you for mercy.
Yo I can't make this.
Yo what the fuck.
Oh wait I can't...
Oh no these guys stop too.
I don't think the...
I think the apples want me to stop.
Okay.
Do I go in?
What happens if I jump down?
Is that blood?
No that's not blood.
Do I jump?
Okay.
I'm gonna do it.
Oh hey welcome back.
Oh hey we are back here again.
Did I make too many?
Maybe I made too many apples.
Wait wait wait.
If I do this...
Maybe one of the apples can...
If I jump?
Maybe if I jump?
Maybe if I jump in...
Oh no that's not it.
No that's not it.
Maybe I... maybe... I'm so fucking confused.
I made too many... she says... I'm creating 5000 more.
Yo, you guys think I made too many apples, guys?
You guys think I made too many apples, guys?
Maybe?
Okay, wait.
Wait, I got this.
I know what to do.
Yo, I know what to do.
I just need to keep duping until...
Wait, no, that doesn't work.
I was like... yo, maybe if I keep...
Okay.
Okay, maybe that ain't it.
That ain't it.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I had to make more.
The key was to make more apples.
The key was to make more apples, guys.
Okay, wait.
Okay.
Maybe?
You guys thought... you guys thought I was stupid.
I'm gonna come... maybe when I come back to figure it out.
I am going figuring it out.
Okay, wait.
Maybe like this.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I got a... I got the idea.
Okay.
And then...
Okay, get an apple close enough.
Okay.
Oh, I... oh, wait.
Wait.
Okay.
Get on my... okay, wait.
Wait.
Okay, then I do this.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Nope, not that.
How the fuck did these apples get over here?
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What if I do this?
Okay.
Okay, I think I made too many apples again.
I think... I think I made...
What?
Oh!
Oh, I think the game just does it because... because they were tired of my shit.
Maybe?
Maybe I do this.
One of you will get there.
One of you will be able to come over.
One day.
Okay, maybe I go farther.
No.
Okay, clearly that ain't it.
Clearly...
Maybe like this?
One of you will make it.
One of you will make it!
I believe in you, apples.
I believe in you, please.
One of you just make it over.
Ooh!
Babies!
Yes!
Baby!
Look at my tiny apples.
I don't think this is it.
I don't think these baby apples are it, guys.
They despawn!
They're so tiny.
I don't think these babies' apples are it, guys.
They're so tiny that they need spots!
I don't think that was it, guys.
One of you will make it!
One of my children will make it through!
Okay.
Maybe.
One of you will make it through.
I believe in you children.
You touch anyone against me every time!
I- You'll make it, I swear!
I just gotta keep making more apples!
One of my children will make it through!
I believe in you!
Yo, this is actual insanity right here.
You guys thought the fucking jumping into the pit was insanity?
I'm out here making- I've been fucking making apples for 20 minutes.
Okay.
Alright, whoa, whoa, whoa, look at here.
My children will make it through!
I don't- God, children, please.
I think I broke it- I broke it again!
I can't make any more apples again!
Oh my god, please!
How many more apples do I make?
If one children doesn't make it, you make a thousand!
I mean, that's what they did in the plague.
They kept making children because the people- They kept dying from the plague!
That's what I learned!
Okay, I think I need a restart.
I figured out why- I figured out why- How to dispose all the apples.
And it's right click.
Alright, here we go again!
Hahaha!
I'm gonna make a big apple.
I figured it out.
I was like- I was like- Alright, biggie boy.
One of you will make it again.
Hahaha!
How do I make it- How do I make you big, mister?
Oh, come on, man!
Come on, man!
One of you will make it.
One of my children will make it!
Shit, here we go again.
I keep spamming apples!
This thing can't figure out more distance, does it?
I don't think it makes it smaller.
No, it goes smaller.
Wait, this apple.
This is the apple.
This is the apple that's gonna live!
Apple!
Yeah, let's just- Apple, you're gonna live.
You're gonna live.
You're gonna live, apple!
You're gonna make it!
One of you will make it!
One of you- Yo, this is so hard.
This is so hard.
Hahaha!
One of them will make it.
One of them will make it eventually.
I believe in all my apple children.
Hahaha!
I'm so happy you're watching this.
Oh my gosh, how many apples can I make?
Oh!
Maybe I make it behind- Oh, I got it.
I got it.
I got it!
Oh!
Look!
Oh no, the baby!
Oh, oh, oh, no!
You were the chosen one!
Hahaha!
What happens to your brain cells if you watch?
Are you watching?
Hahaha!
Your cells are clean, but not joyless.
Not joyless.
I'm so sad.
That was their closest one.
That was our closest one.
Hahaha!
That apple was our closest one.
Oh!
Oh my god, I have flinged over.
Okay.
Okay, maybe my- Maybe- No!
No!
Hahaha!
I spent so many times- You're gonna send me some apples after watching this stream.
I think it's time to reset again, guys.
Maybe.
Okay, maybe.
Maybe if I do this.
Apples!
Come on here!
Yeah!
Come on!
One of you won't make it!
Hahaha!
You can't all fucking fly into the pit!
Physics will fucking stop you one day!
Hahaha!
I'll just need physics to stop working and then we'll be fine, chat.
As long- Hahaha!
I need the physics engines to stop working and we'll be- We'll win.
This is the time to backseat.
Wait, okay, okay.
Alright, alright.
Alright, I'm restarting.
Okay, okay.
What do you mean?
Woo!
I'm so fucking smart!
Alright, alright, get in here!
Get- Oh!
Baby apples.
Get in here.
Get in here!
Oh, I fucked up!
Okay.
One of you will make it!
One of my children will make it!
Hahaha!
I don't think they're making it, guys.
Yo, my children.
Um, I don't think they made it, guys.
Wait, okay.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Come over here.
Come over here!
Hahaha!
You guys will become- Wait, will this work?
Oh my god, will you guys work?
Will you tiny apples?
Hahaha!
The tiny apples worked!
Oh, I did too!
Oh my god, the tiny apples made it!
It was- There you go, tiny apples!
Hahaha!
Oh my god, the tiny apples!
The tiny apples!
Thank you for the 500,000 bits!
I love you!
Oh my god!
Hahaha!
Size doesn't matter!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, tiny apple!
Hahaha!
Oh!
Oh my god, tiny apple!
I think I fucked Tom.
Hahaha!
Oh, we only have like- 10 minutes more to see.
Oh shit!
Hahaha!
Oh my god, Grandpa, I hope- Uh...
Grandpa, I hope you have a good apple pie after all the apples!
I hope you have a good apple pie after all the apples!
Hahaha!
After all the apples!
Hello.
Name is my Pierce, Dr. Glenn.
To the Somnusculpt welcome experience, team of your care leader- Oh my god, no, you're not playing!
Peng, what's happening?
I'm trying to do puzzles, lunatic!
That's what's happening!
...cutting a tomorrow can bright.
And...
Oh...
Man...
I was bored to- What is- now I'm an apple!
Hahaha!
Lunatic, I'm just trying to- I'm trying to figure out- My brain is just trying to figure out shit right now.
I don't wanna play Apex with you!
Maybe after this, after this, lunatic, I need to finish this variety game.
What's this?
Oh, that looks nice.
That looks nice after the tiny apple incident.
That looks really nice.
Thank you for the last- I watched a butter- Thank you, Sol, for the 10 minutes!
Thank you.
I'm gonna have nightmares about the apple now.
Thank you for the laughs.
I watched a butterfinger for this.
I'm glad you enjoyed the stream.
Oh, that's nice.
Oh, that's not nice.
Hahaha!
Hello.
My name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
This is a notification that you have reappeared on our monitoring system after a premiere of your episode.
Please continue to do whatever you did most recently.
Hello.
What?
About to head out?
The tiny apple is the one that did it for me.
Oh, we're back here again.
Dream Soda.
Oh!
Why is it getting darker?
Oh, cause I'm gonna fall.
Oh.
Hey there.
It's a house.
Whoa!
How big can I make the house?
The victorious tiny apple should have a name.
Hahaha!
Oh, did I make it too...
Oh, I made it too big.
Alright, time to make you small.
Small?
Oh.
Oh, too small.
Too small.
Are you done?
No, are you talking?
Good night, malicious.
Are you heading to bed?
Are you...
Are you saying good night to someone else?
Hahaha!
Oh, hey Ruby.
Welcome back, Ruby.
Tiny.
Is this too big?
Oh, tiny.
Alright, wait.
Alright.
I need to make this bigger.
And then...
Oh.
This needs to be big.
Oh, wait, no.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, no, not yet.
This needs to be bigger.
It needs to be bigger!
Oh, that is really big.
Hahaha!
Now I should fit.
Wait, I'm not done yet.
Whiskey!
Whiskey, thank you so much for the raid!
Hi everyone!
Hello!
Is everyone coming from Whiskey's stream?
Hello, hello!
Thank you so much for the follows, iFurBlades.
Thank you, thank you.
What were you streaming, Whiskey?
Oh, Demon's Souls!
Holy sh...
I think I played Demon's Souls.
No, Bloodborne.
I don't think I've ever played Demon's Souls.
Hahaha!
Thank you so much for the follows, different ways.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a... have a bloodhurt.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, I'm playing super, super limit on my brain.
I got stuck on the apple part for like 20 minutes.
Hahaha!
I had a fun...
I had a fun time playing Demon's...
Thank you so much for the follows, Simon.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a... have a bloodhurt.
Thank you so much.
For those of you who don't know, I'm usually an emote artist.
But sometimes... today's Variety Friday.
So I'm playing variety games right now.
Playing some super...
uh... super liminal.
And... and...
I am doing very well.
If you guys ask chat.
I'm already 10 minutes... I played this game for 10 minutes already.
And I'm already 80% done.
Isn't that crazy, guys?
Uh, don't believe what the timestamp says.
I'm actually... I'm actually like...
20 minutes... I'm 10 minutes into the game.
10 minutes into the game.
I'm almost done.
Oh, I don't like this.
Are we in the...
Oh, is it murder again?
Oh, come on.
Are we getting murdered again?
But yeah, if you guys don't know, I was the one that did...
I was the one that did...
Whiskey's Halloween emote.
Everything should have now reverted to being soothing and therapeutic.
You may be receiving this message in error.
Oh, house.
Oh.
Oh, I'm so smart.
Look at this.
Boom.
Look at that.
You thought... you thought...
After conquering apples, nothing can hurt me now.
Nothing.
I've conquered the apples.
Now...
Now I can conquer everything else.
Where the fuck do I go now?
Are you still dreaming?
You think you only have four hours of sleep?
Oh, window.
What the fuck do I do with you?
What?
What do I do with you?
Okay, I'll make you bigger.
Up?
Hey.
Oh, I thought it was a window.
I thought... I thought...
I thought you couldn't go through it.
I got you baited so hard there.
Alright.
Hello.
My name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
And I'd like to read you my favorite inspirational quote by me.
The worst thing you can do is focus on negativity.
Oh.
Okay.
It won't spare you from the cage of death...
Why are you tiny?
...the old shell of sheep's nature...
...and the eventual loss of everything you've ever held dear.
Okay, okay.
Whatever you do, don't focus on that.
Thank you.
Alright, now you're big.
Nice.
Okay, now you make you bigger.
Apparently.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright.
Okay.
Apparently you're not getting any bigger.
So I gotta put you higher.
Okay, now you're big.
Oh, I think that's too big.
Okay, how the fuck do I get in?
No.
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
See, look at that.
I'm a genius.
Oh, why is there a vent?
Oh, I don't like this.
Now I'm in a vent?
What?
Oh.
Hey there.
...
Oh.
Oh, baby.
Baby?
Oh?
What do I do with you?
I still don't know.
I pretended to understand.
Wait, wait.
Oh!
I'm so smart!
Why am I so- I'm so tiny!
I'm so slow!
Baby.
Now I'm baby.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking slow now.
Your laugh is adorable.
Oh, thank you.
What the fuck happened?
I'm baby now.
I think I broke the gate.
Aina, thank you so much for the follow.
I'm so happy.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Have a butt heart.
Also, thank you so much, you soy boy.
And Vincent, cute.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Now I'm actual baby.
Okay, I don't- Okay, I really- I don't think- I think I fucked up, chat.
I think I actually- I think- Wow!
I think I fucked up.
I don't think I'm supposed to be tiny, guys.
I don't think I'm supposed to be tiny.
Luck Lad, thank you so much for the gift of thumbs.
Thank you, thank you.
Can you get some Berknights real quick from Luck Lad?
Guys, I think I- I think I broke the gate, guys.
Wait.
Let me got this.
Oh no.
It's stuck.
No, I got this.
Oh, what did you do?
I don't even know what I did.
We helped Babydor, now Babydor is here to watch us grow.
I don't know.
Okay, wait, let me go through here.
Please let me through.
Let me through.
Okay, okay, I need to be a bit bigger.
Okay.
Oh, now it's too big.
It needs to be the perfect... Please, please mister, I wanna be big again!
I wanna be big again!
I think I broke the game, guys!
Please, come back!
Oh, wait.
Let me in.
How do I break games?
I don't understand.
I keep breaking this game.
I keep breaking it.
Let me in, please.
Please, let me in.
This is actually how smart I am to keep it broken.
Yo, it won't even let me get big again.
Let me in.
Oh my god.
Yo, okay, you know what?
I can't even... Look how slow I am.
Look how slow I am.
I'm trying to get... I'm trying to get used to the mouse bar in the game engine now.
Look, oh my god.
I'm so slow.
Holy shit.
I don't think I was supposed to be this tiny, guys.
I don't think I'm supposed to be this tiny.
Okay.
Okay, don't worry.
I'm not restarting.
Alright, alright, alright.
I just need to... Please.
Please, mister.
Please.
Whoa!
He walked through.
Where did he go?
Oh, now it's gone forever.
Oh, it's gone forever now.
No.
Alright.
Okay, if I walk through that door...
Okay, he's like...
No, I'm gonna...
If I go through this big door, I just need to make it through, guys.
I just... I just need to make it through.
Oh my god.
I wish there was a sprint button now.
I wish I was...
Oh, we're almost there, guys.
We're almost there.
Where is this door gonna lead us now?
We're so close, chat.
We're so close.
Oh my god.
We're almost there.
I think our domain has gone before.
Where is it gonna lead us?
The door is closed.
I'm...
Wouldn't it be great if we went out of bounds after this?
Dude, is this Ant-Man?
Are we in an Ant-Man film right now?
Alright.
Oh my god.
Look at the... The door is...
The door is not... The door doesn't know where it's leading us.
Oh my god.
Even the door doesn't know.
You can see that?
Wait, I'm not even... I'm too small.
I'm too small to jump in the door.
It won't even let me in.
I'm too small.
Please.
Please let me in.
I'm too baby.
And we clip through.
Alright, time to clip through, guys.
I think we have... I think... I think we gotta come back to the checkpoint.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is the castle?
Yeah, I don't think... After traveling so far...
It seems like we gotta send that to the checkpoint.
Where is it gonna lead me?
Oh, it's back here.
Okay.
Alright, here we go again.
Okay, what we've learned today...
We've learned something today.
We learned that you can actually be...
You can actually be too small, apparently.
There is a way to be too small in the game.
There is a way.
And I found that way.
Okay, I fucked up again.
Size doesn't matter.
There's a thing called being too small, apparently.
Isn't that crazy?
Who would've thought there's a thing called being too small in the game?
Who would've thought, guys?
Not me.
Okay, where the fuck is the door?
Here you are.
Alright.
And then... through this...
We gotta pick you up.
Alright, let's go.
Okay, am I gonna fuck this up again, guys?
How do I do this?
Okay.
Place it on top of the...
How do I place it?
It won't let me...
Oh, there it is.
I was like, would it be a good place to...
Oh, there it goes.
First try, two.
Apparently so.
Hello, my name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
And I'd like to thank you for triggering every single one of our 823 emergency protocols.
This will assist us greatly in improving the system for future patients.
Congratulations.
Anyway, you're now headed in the right direction.
And we should be able to initiate the emergency exit protocol shortly.
Oh, wait, what?
Okay, if I make two big ones...
Remember what you said, you started ten minutes.
God, almost...
Yeah, see?
It's only...
Five minutes only passed.
What do you mean?
Only five minutes have passed, guys.
What the fuck do I'm doing?
Did I get bigger?
I don't even...
I don't even know.
Am I getting bigger, guys?
Am I doing it?
Oh, what is...
Wait...
Oh!
Wait.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm babying?
Hey, it's me, baby.
It's me, baby.
I don't think I was supposed to be baby.
Okay, man.
Did I get...
Become big?
I might get bigger.
Okay, make me mega big.
All right.
All right, now I'm...
Okay, I'm...
I'm gonna do it.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Wait, no, no, no, no.
Big, big, big baby.
Mega big baby.
I know what I'm doing, guys.
Don't worry.
All right, this is taking...
What do you mean?
This is...
There it is.
A mega big baby.
I don't think we're supposed to...
You can't touch the light here.
Yeah, there's nothing to do with the light here.
We all know Doki's time transcends real time.
True.
I don't know.
Oh, oh!
Okay.
Big baby time.
Woo!
We cannot go bigger?
Oh, wait, I fucked up.
Am I smaller now?
Wait.
Can I not get bigger?
Did I fuck up?
I think I might have fucked up again.
Wait, if I keep going back and forth, maybe I'll... I just gotta keep going through!
Now I'm big baby!
Yeah!
Oh, I'm too big now.
I'm too big now.
I just have to keep going forward.
Okay.
Alright.
Come on, get big.
Okay, come on, get big.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, so I think I fucked up.
I think I fucked up!
Wait.
Okay, but I need to fucking make the door big though.
Door won't go big, guys!
Door won't go big!
Oh, no!
Door, do I... Door swap forever!
Door swap forever, guys!
Okay, malicious.
The problem here is that I can't... The problem here is that I'm too big to go through doors now.
Because I'm... I'm too big to go through doors right now.
I fucked up.
I became too big.
There's a thing... So size... Size doesn't matter apparently.
Oh,
I'm gonna make you big!
How do I... Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, I'm so smart!
Oh!
Big... Oh, wait, no, that's not a big door.
Get out of the way.
Big door!
Oh, wait, I'm... Wait, I fucked up again.
Alright, and then tiny door.
Alright.
Tiny door.
Oh, wait, that's a big door.
Wait, wait, wait, I'm fucking up.
I don't know perspectives anymore.
I don't know perspectives anymore, guys.
Alright, there we go.
Boop!
Alright, look at that.
Look at that.
How did you learn the mechanics?
I'm so proud.
Yo, I learned about perspectives after... after two hours and twenty... Alex!
Alex 41 years.
Alex 41 months!
Woo!
Give me some bark nights real quick for Alex, one of the... one of my oldest supporters and subs.
Thank you, Alex!
Here, get some fucking bark nights real quick for Alex.
Woo!
Thank you, thank you!
Boop!
Alright.
Now we're baby.
Okay.
Where do I go?
I'm so fucking pleased.
I wanna be bigger.
I'm so so... I wanna... please just make me a big boy now.
Mom, I wanna be a big boy.
I don't wanna be small anymore.
Look at the little baby man.
I'm going to bring the... Oh, am I supposed to bring the doors with me?
No, that can't be right.
No, I... I... No, that can't be right.
How can I be big?
Oh, maybe you are right.
Oh.
I fell.
What is that?
Wait!
What?
Excuse me?
What was that?
Oh.
Oh, hey!
Wait.
Oh, I made you too small.
Slowly falling.
Slowly... Wapig!
Wapig!
Wapig, are you gonna sing for us today?
Hey.
Very slowly heading over there.
Later, buddy.
Oh my god, thank god.
Oh my god, Keith!
Thank you so much for the raid, Keith!
Thank you!
What were you playing?
Oh, we were playing no game.
No game.
Hi everyone from Keith's stream.
Hi, are you looking forward to tomorrow, Keith?
For the Dory's charity event?
I like how it said you weren't playing anything.
Thank you so much for the follow ads.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Have a blood heart.
Thank you so much.
Big boy raid of 63.
No game, no life.
Did you have fun?
What were you doing in VRChat?
Alright.
Let's go.
Meeting for Cardboard Lovers Association.
Damn.
Agenda rule.
What the fuck?
It won't even let me raid.
Is...
Is it already tomorrow?
No, tomorrow starts when I go to sleep.
Green fat.
Alright.
Are we in a good stream, Keith?
I hope you had a good stream.
Cause all I'm... I'm fucking speedrunning this boy.
I'm speedrunning the fuck out of this game.
It's been five minutes since I started the game.
And look where we are.
90%.
Almost done.
Hey.
Error.
Error logged by.
Orientation protocol.
Standby for analysis.
I broke the game twice.
Oh, wait.
Why is there blood again?
Wait a minute.
Consistent with an increase in fear, hopelessness, and frustration.
This is inconceivable as somnascult therapy is coming to correlate with a decrease in these emotions.
GM beat the world record on her first try.
More beans?
You're right.
It's just more beans.
Yeah, somebody spilled ketchup, right?
Impossible.
Reformulating.
Oh.
Oh, I thought that says... I thought that says murder again.
Patient requires additional somnascult therapy.
I thought that says murder.
Emergency exit protocol cannot proceed.
Wake up.
Oh, yeah.
That doesn't... Yeah, that's not fucky at all.
That's not fucky at all.
Continue with somnascult therapy indefinitely on an indefinite basis.
Oh, I'm not scared.
As all orientation resources have been exhausted.
Okay, I'm gonna go to bed because I've been up all day and night.
So goodnight, may full and chat good luck with beating the speedrun record.
I know you can do it.
Woah!
Like, goodnight, Zio.
Goodnight.
Oh, it's 3 AM.
Oh, you gotta just ride home.
Oh, hey there, guys.
Hey.
Oh, hey.
Oh, I'm stuck now, too.
Hey there, guys.
Can you catch me?
Oh!
Hey there, guys.
Okay.
Oh,
my God.
What's going... Did I break it?
What if I break it again?
What's going on?
Oh, my God!
Where am I?
This is like the most stressful morning try that I wake up.
Here you guys.
Oh!
Hey.
You got a seizure?
Alright.
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
We're gonna wrap it.
Hey there.
Alright,
where do we go?
This is like one big fierce dream and we have a big hearted bird brain crawl at the wheel.
Dude, what the fuck do I do?
Hello?
Oh!
Hey there.
Oh, I have to go out into the sky.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
I forgot this is how you do it.
Hey there.
Hello.
My name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
Thank you for completing the Song of Sculpt Standard Orientation Protocol.
Yes?
Before we begin the first phase of therapy, I'd like to briefly describe the finite and fragile nature of the dreamscape.
Well, you didn't finish explaining the dreamscape.
Whoa!
Yo,
I don't know how to...
I can barely walk properly.
In normal games.
Let alone this.
This is so fucky.
How do I get out of here?
Yeah, this hurts me.
I dream like that.
I kept on trying to wake up.
Then I got dragged.
All of a sudden, after two more times, I finally woke up.
Yeah, this is so fucky.
This is...
What do you want me to do?
Oh.
Okay.
Up?
Oh, I'm going to go up.
Okay.
I'm going to go up.
Hey there, guys.
Hey, I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
How do I...
How do I get out of here?
Stupa!
Thank you so much for the raid.
Thank you.
I hope you had a good stream, Stupa.
Oh, you're playing Valorant.
Have you did what?
I hope you...
Are you playing Raid?
Thank you so much for the raid.
Hi, everyone.
Hi.
I am very fucking confused, but...
Oh, door.
Baby door?
Baby door!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, hey.
Okay.
Baby door saved my life.
Now, where do I go?
Oh, no.
Me stream froze.
I refresh.
Here we go.
Look at that.
I'm so smart.
I had a good 100-year stream.
I don't know how to stop you streaming the raid anymore.
Yeah, I stream at like degenerate times.
Very, very degenerate times, Stupa.
I'm going to go up.
Very degenerate.
All right.
Of course, nothing is more challenging than the difficulty of changing perspective.
I had to stream at like after midnight because that's when my brain turns on.
But then I only had like four hours of sleep, so I don't know if it's technically on or not.
No spooks here.
Nothing to worry about.
Oh, really?
Oh, really, Crimbo?
Really?
Thank you for the $5.
I don't know why I don't believe you.
I'm sorry.
Hey, hey, listen.
Oh, hey.
I'm listening.
How do I do this?
Bow.
Bow?
Oh!
Where am I?
Stairs.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Let me in!
Oh!
I don't wanna go upstairs.
Hey.
Oh god!
Wait, what was that sound?
Wait, wait what?
What do you mean?
No key, it's not touching things, you've become too small, you got stuck on the wall, now you broke the elevator, are you proud?
Oh, somebody has to... oh hey, I did it.
Yeah!
I did it!
Wow!
How am I fucking up?
I don't understand!
Wow!
Okay, I don't understand how I'm fucking this up.
This is it.
What?
Oh!
Okay.
Boop.
Oh.
Here, oh!
What?
Okay.
Alright.
Go the opposite way, what?
Go to go...
Here?
Oh!
Okay, this will work eventually.
Perception is not reality.
Okay.
Okay, that makes total sense.
I... that makes total sense.
Okay, wait.
It's gonna... it'll let me through!
If I just keep going, it's gonna let me through!
Maybe if I stop... okay, I just need to not look... not look at the signs.
If I don't look at the signs... if I don't look at the signs... maybe... maybe that's it.
Okay, that's not it.
Just keep moving, I just gotta keep moving.
I just gotta keep moving.
I...
Oh my god, wait please.
I don't get it!
What do you want me to do?
No, I'm not looking!
Okay, okay, okay.
If I do this... alright, maybe I do this.
Okay, clearly that thing ain't it.
Okay, what do you want me... I don't understand.
I'm not looking at the signs!
I'm looking at the floor!
What if I just go backwards?
Oh!
How about this?
I'll just go backwards!
Oh, what are they gonna do?
Oh!
I went backwards and it worked!
Oh, I guess that was the thing!
Just go backwards!
Wait, is it?
Wait a minute.
Is it actually?
Do I just go backwards?
Wait a minute.
What?
I swear!
No, okay, it wasn't the backwards.
It wasn't backwards, chat.
It was not backwards.
I don't know the pattern here.
I don't know the pattern.
Okay.
Okay, but this has been more successful.
This has been more successful!
Going backwards has been more successful!
What?
Okay, wait.
Okay, wait a minute.
I got no idea.
Do you think I have an idea?
Look!
It's been dinging when I go backwards!
Okay.
Alright.
Exit.
Perception is not reality.
Okay, cool.
What the fuck?
Okay.
What?
How am I wrong?
How am I wrong, lol?
Okay.
Well then.
Apparently I've been doing better.
I've been doing better walking backwards.
Hahaha.
Yo, what the fuck?
How am I doing better?
Backwards.
Better working backwards.
I don't even know the pattern!
I don't know the pattern of this.
I don't know the pattern, guys.
But it went ding, ding, ding.
Oh my god.
Dude, fuck you.
I got...
Hall 5!
I've made it to hall number 5.
And I still don't know the pattern.
Hahaha.
I mean it's all fine!
I will never know how to do this.
As long as I just don't- apparently I just need to not look at the signs.
Oh shit!
Where do I go now?
Whoa!
Oh!
Deep!
Oh wow okay okay.
Okay this is actual insanity right here.
This is- this is like more game.
This is actual insanity right now guys.
We're actually going crazy.
Oh my god please.
Okay.
Okay okay left.
Left!
I realized how totally...
Yo I fucking- yo dude I hate this.
How
am I getting it wrong?
Okay.
Now all it says every third time you don't get it right on the third time will be the opposite of the- of the other- What?
What?
Okay maybe if I do this and I go boom and then boom and then...
Okay.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Boom.
Alright.
Alright alright I got this.
Boom.
Alright.
What?
How?
I
- I give up.
Oh.
I give up.
I don't understand the pattern.
What's the pattern?
What is the pattern?
Why am I wrong now?
Okay.
How are you wrong?
Alright.
Okay.
What
is - wait you get there you'll need to look at the exit.
Look at which way the sign is pointing and face the opposite way while walking out the exit.
What?
Oh so I do this?
Is that what you want me to do?
Oh no now I'm just- Right right then left don't look the right right the last time or- Right right then right.
Right right then right.
Right right left.
Left.
Oh you're all confusing me.
Oh you're
all confusing me.
Okay now which way?
Which way do I go chat?
Which way?
Alright lead me guys lead me.
Am I up here?
Okay basically look the opposite of the exit sign.
Okay and then go the opposite way.
Alright I'm doing it.
Oh oh alright.
And then opposite.
Oh oh I'm doing it.
Oh and then look the opposite.
And then.
Oh we did it.
Yeah I'm back to the exit.
Backseat gaming.
Backseat gaming has solved the game.
Backseat gaming has won yet again.
Oh my god.
Whew.
Yeah I don't know why backwards work.
Apparently walking backwards was way way helpful for some fucking reason.
For some reason walking backwards made me more progress.
Oh my god apparently I broke the game yet again by walking backwards apparently.
Oh shit wait what the fuck.
Wait did I fuck up?
Wait a minute.
It was half.
So you have to make the wrong path.
The first thing you look at is the dead end.
You see it look at the black.
What the fuck did I do?
What did I do?
Beat him man.
Oh god.
I just broke the game.
Hahaha.
Oh.
Yo.
Hey.
Where am I?
Alright.
Whoa.
I don't like it.
Oh I don't.
Whoa.
Where's the light?
Where is the light?
Hahaha.
You are crazy now.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Whoa.
I can't do anything.
What do I do if I can't.
Hahaha.
I can't do anything if I can't grab anything.
Oh.
Whoa.
I'm crash batting it.
Arrow.
Where
the fuck is arrow?
Arrow.
Did I fuck up?
I think I fucked up guys.
Hahaha.
Oh.
No I didn't.
I'm so smart.
Oh.
I don't like that.
Hahaha.
Is it officially cutting that?
Hey guys.
Hey everyone.
Oh.
Hey.
Hey guys.
Oh hey there.
Hahaha.
How do I get out of here?
Hey everyone.
Oh hey.
What the fuck?
When did this showed up?
Why was this here?
Hello?
Oh hey.
Oh.
Okay.
Hahaha.
Oh shit.
Watch time is broke.
Hahaha.
Stream elements is getting fucked up.
Hey.
Hey everyone.
Alright.
This is highly unusual.
It appears you have entered the Sun Ascult's diagnostic framework.
Patients do not have access to this stream.
Oh.
Wait.
How do I make big?
Big?
Diagnostic warning.
Unrealistic user.
Dream objects may result in dream integrity fail state.
Big?
Big.
Okay.
There we go.
Hahaha.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh it wasn't supposed to be big.
What?
Hahaha.
It wasn't supposed to be big.
Wait a minute.
If I put it here.
Maybe.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
Here we go.
And then I go through here.
And then.
Hey guys.
Hey everyone.
Hey there.
My friend.
We get inside.
Here?
Oh.
Hey everyone.
I'm big.
What the fuck do I do?
Oh.
I don't know.
Hahaha.
I go smaller?
I don't know about that guys.
I think the last time we went too small.
We fucked up.
Hahaha.
Okay wait.
Okay.
Okay here we go.
Okay no.
Okay wait here we go.
Wait.
Boop boop.
There we go.
We did it.
And now we're small.
Wait we're big.
Now we're big.
I'm so fucking confused guys.
Alright.
Okay wait wait wait wait.
I'm gonna be small again.
And then.
Oh thank you so much for the follow depth size.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
What other things?
What are things?
Paradox prevention protocols may not be fully implemented.
What do you mean?
Hahaha.
Where is the confusion?
Thank you so much for the follow though.
I really do appreciate it.
Alright here we go.
And now I'm big.
Boop boop.
Alright.
There has to be something.
Carry.
Oh!
I'm carrying myself.
Wooo!
Oh I don't like that.
That's weird.
They have a fun art to test size.
Hahaha.
Oh.
Oh I'm sorry.
Wow I'm sorry.
Hahaha.
I don't think they like that.
Oh I don't feel so good.
Hahaha.
You don't think they like that?
Oh shit.
I'm disappearing.
Please paradox for creating refrains.
Hello.
Hey.
Hey there.
Woah!
Oh I don't feel so good.
Hahaha.
Oh.
This is apparently heaven and hell.
Alright.
Hello.
My name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
Who else watched the stream?
Hahaha.
I found myself in a place where I understood that each of us begins as nothing.
Where everything you perceive is shaped by seeing it exactly the same.
Exactly the way I wanted to.
White space.
Alright.
I didn't really process all twelve.
Holy shit twelve.
I think I watched like three hours of it.
I watched like every hour of it.
Like every um three or four hours of Anus.
Anus.
Sorry.
On this penis.
Sorry I'm getting a fucking.
I'm having a mini stroke right now.
Hahaha.
But yeah I also watched like bits of it.
And then I watched the guy get a tattoo.
And like his.
Their like memorable clips and stuff like that.
And then.
Um.
And watched how them.
Oh!
Delete.
Watch them delete the.
The.
The YouTube channel.
Alright.
Where do I go?
Jump?
Am I gonna be tall again?
Oh no it's just an exit.
Wait.
What the fuck?
I'm going through the exit.
Where is this gonna take me?
Where are you gonna take me sir?
Oh.
Oh my lost.
Imagine this game was about a man having a delusion.
And just went to five different places.
While babbling random nonsense.
And passes out.
Oh.
Wait that's not fair.
I'm not tall.
That's not fair.
Oh.
Oh what the fuck?
What did I do?
Wow!
What is this?
What did I do?
Oh.
Is this another.
Whoa.
What is this?
Oh I can't even.
Oh.
Wait where did it go?
Did I break it?
Where did you go?
Oh hey there.
I didn't break it.
Okay.
Alright this is a stepping stone.
Every time I'm just like did I break this?
Oh shit.
I keep thinking I broke this.
I'm breaking the game.
Wait how do I make you big?
How do I make you?
Okay wait.
Wait.
Are you big?
You're not big.
I'll make you big.
Oh no.
Why are you small now?
I don't remember how I make you big.
Oh.
Why are you so small?
No you're too small.
Oh there we go.
There we go.
Wait why are you not getting big?
I don't understand.
How am I fucking up?
How are you not getting big?
Okay.
Alright.
Hey key back.
Okay.
Alright.
But it keeps getting bigger.
It keeps getting small.
Wait wait wait wait wait.
Okay.
Are you big now?
Are you big?
Oh you're big.
Okay there we go.
I did it.
I'm tall now.
This is the list of all the things I could imagine.
Because with the lifetime of life itself behind me.
And all of the weight that it carried.
I was like.
I realized that seeing things the way I wanted to.
Was not as easy as it used to be.
Alright.
We're going here now.
Oh that's a big light switch.
Woah.
Okay I don't want to.
Okay.
Hahaha.
I'll guess what you just heard.
Okay okay.
Haha.
Woah.
That's it.
Okay.
Okay lost her mic.
I feel like.
I don't know about you guys.
How much longer this stream for.
I have no idea crowd slay.
Until I finish this game apparently.
Where do I go up?
Do I need to position itself again?
Welcome back, sneaking!
Pointing afterwards?
I'm not sure yet.
I'm not sure.
I'm just... Oh, I'll give you a kiss.
That's for Autumn.
Oh, what do I do?
Alright, one more.
I guess this is the hour.
This is the hour.
This is... Oh God!
How do I get out of here?
Oh no!
Please!
I'm looking up.
I'm going up!
Doo doo doo!
Oh!
What the fuck?
Did
I?
Yo, these instructions are not...
These instructions are not helpful at all.
I guess I go down now.
Hey!
Wasn't I just here?
Hello?
Hey guys!
I'm back again!
Maybe if I keep doing it...
If I keep doing it...
And maybe if I keep doing it...
Maybe if I just keep going through...
I'll find the answer.
That's...
That's how this... Oh no!
I just go through the white...
I just go through this...
That's all I have to do.
Alright.
Oh shit.
This watcher makes me feel giddy.
Makes me laugh.
Aww, that's really sweet!
That's really sweet.
I'm glad you're having a good time.
Um, no.
You see, I needed a game for Variety Friday.
And so here we are.
Oh.
Hey there.
I'm using this to...
Oh wait, no never mind.
Yo, I thought I figured it out.
And I fell down so I don't like...
Oh!
Oh wait, I just have to...
Okay wait.
Wait, I got it.
I got it.
I got it now.
Then I do this.
And I go BAM!
And then I do this.
And then I go BAM!
Dude, I'm so smart.
Look at this.
I've never tried Stanley Parable.
Never.
Never tried it before.
Casually dismissing the beauty of the game.
What beauty!
It was just...
It was just a chess board.
What's so beautiful about a chess board?
What?
What do you mean?
Hey, geez.
Did I make you bigger?
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm making you bigger, mister.
I'm making you a big boy.
Yeah, big boy now.
Did I make you bigger here?
Oh, I made you small.
Wait, okay.
Big boy time.
It's big boy time.
Oh, shit.
This is a big boy.
Alright.
I got this.
I know what to do.
My brain has expanded.
My brain has expanded through this.
Look at that.
Big cheese now.
And then...
And then I do this.
I do, I do, I do.
In the wrong...
Wait!
Wait,
this is not how you play this?
This is not...
That fucked up.
Alright.
My brain has shrunk.
I'm so confused.
I'm so confused, too.
No!
Geez!
Am I supposed to bring it here?
No, I can't.
Yeah, it's locked.
Oh my god, my cheese!
I need to do this all over again!
My cheese!
Okay, wait.
Okay.
The cheese betrayed just like it betrayed my stomach.
Tom no make big boy.
Big boy time!
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
I know this mechanic.
Okay.
Okay, I need to make it bigger.
I need to make...
Oh, I fucked up!
Why do I keep fucking up?
Why do I keep fucking up, chat?
Okay.
Alright.
Cheese.
Cheese!
Please!
Oh my god.
Please just be big!
That's all I want you to be!
Cheese!
Oh my god!
How did it get smaller?
How did you get smaller cheese?
I don't understand!
How did you get smaller?
Please let me up.
Cheese please.
Please, I need you to stop getting smaller.
Cheese!
No!
I can't!
No, my own!
My own fucked up!
Okay.
Alright.
Big O.
Big O, you gotta get big.
That's right.
Oh, Big O is a bit too big.
How do I make you bigger?
Yes.
Alright cheese, now it's your turn.
Now it's your turn cheese.
Cheese please.
Cheese.
Please cheese, I need you to be big too.
Please.
I fucked up so many times.
Just give me the...
Oh my god!
Why am I stuck at this level?
Why am I stuck here?
Because I know this part.
Oh my god!
It doesn't even make me...
Now you're big.
I'll just keep...
If it keeps hitting me in the head, I'll get big.
Okay.
Alright, there we go cheese.
I should have just put it on top of my head.
That's all I needed.
Alright cheese here.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, was I supposed to go up here?
I did all of that and I wasn't supposed to go up here?
Are you kidding me?
I worked so hard.
Making a big block and big cheese.
And there's a...
And I can't even get out there.
What is the point of life?
This is stupid.
I'm out of here.
Oh, I can't even get out of here.
What does this want me to do?
What do you want from me?
What do you want from me cheese?
I'm just gonna sit here.
Trying to fucking figure out what this wants from me.
I'm so confused.
Hahaha.
What do you mean remembering the chess puzzle from earlier?
What do you mean?
Oh.
My
god, I'm going fucking crazy here.
Hahaha.
Stupid fucking cheese.
Oh my god.
This is actually making me crazy apparently.
Hahaha.
No!
Okay.
Wait.
I'm gonna figure this out again.
Oh, you wanna make you big?
I forgot.
I forgot how to make big.
Hahaha.
Quebec thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Big.
Okay, okay.
Very slowly and surely, we make you big.
Oh, have a...
Have a butt heart.
Quebec.
Big.
Please just...
Please just let me go through.
Please.
Writing, but I still don't know how to make things big.
Promise I'm on Doki's stream.
Hahaha.
I still don't know how to make big things apparently.
Oh god.
This is so trippy.
Oh my god.
I don't...
This is actually so fucking trippy, guys.
What the fuck?
Where are you?
Where am I?
Hahaha.
Oh.
Oh, now I'm in the alarm clock.
That is like actually a nightmare, right?
Oh my gosh.
What the fuck?
Hahaha.
7.59.
AM.
Oh, I don't like the flashy lights.
Oh.
Hahaha.
Yo, it's 3... it's 3.33 AM.
It is 8 AM.
Okay.
Goodnight.
Hahaha.
Oh.
What's with these sounds?
Hello.
My name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
And by now, you may have realized that all of this has happened exactly the way it was supposed to.
Oh.
Hey there.
You see, everyone who comes to the institute does so because they feel that they are no longer in control of something important to them.
Oh my god.
I actually haven't hydrated for three hours.
What the fuck?
Hahaha.
But, more often than not, the problem is that...
Yeah, I'm gonna need some water right now.
Oh my gosh.
My arm's weak now.
I'm gonna need some water right now.
Thanks for the reminder.
The problem is that we become so afraid of failure that we refuse to see our problem.
And so, we do the same things again and again and again.
And therein, of course, we find exactly the failure we were looking for.
Oh, I really retraced it.
Oh, hey.
Oh, look.
There's my bouncy castle.
There it is.
I made that.
Oh.
You see things again and again.
Sounds so like... I wonder who could that be.
Hahaha.
Your life will always be a struggle.
And you will always have to... Like, I burped that.
Hahaha.
But today, you had the chance to see things differently.
Even though it meant facing obstacles that seemed impossible at first, you thought outside the box.
And you overcame them.
Because you saw things from every angle.
You saw things... You understood them for what they really are.
I don't think so, dude.
Hahaha.
Dude, I burped my entire way through.
I still don't know how to properly play this game.
Hahaha.
What is this?
Brandon, this is super little, but we're almost done with it, though.
You meant burp first, then?
Yes, absolutely.
Hahaha.
Hey.
Oh, I can't press the soda machine anymore.
You'll be back in the real world.
Some part of you will say that none of this was real.
So, how could it have really meant anything?
But, just like the power of perspective itself, it would have been as real as you believed it to be.
All you've got to do is wait.
Here I am.
Oh, we did it!
I did it.
Hahaha.
Woo!
World record pace!
Seven minutes!
Damn.
Holy shit.
Did we beat the world record?
I think so.
It's like seven minutes, right?
Hahaha.
Gratulant.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I gotta submit it to the ADGD cuties.
I gotta submit it.
Now tell me, how do you make things bigger?
Hahaha.
I still don't know.
I still don't know how to play this game.
I honestly, I keep fucking up making things bigger and smaller for some reason.
Hahaha.
First try, no success.
Thank you so much for the follow, Brandon.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Have a, have a play heart.
Thank you.
Holy shit.
I am so tired.
My brain was not supposed to think about, like, I think I broke the game like three or four times, chat.
Like, I don't even think, I think I, the apple, the apple stage, I think I brute forced the apple stage.
Hahaha.
I think, I think I solved the apple puzzle only by sheer luck.
By sheer luck and breaking the physics of the game.
The tiny apples.
I don't think the tiny apples are supposed to work that way, chat.
Hahaha.
I can't believe the little apples actually work.
Oh my god.
Shit.
Hahaha.
Oh my god, guys.
Oh god.
Thank you so much for the follow, you are, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a, have a play heart.
Thank you so much.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
Hahaha.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so, thanks for dreaming.
Hahaha.
I don't think this was, I was like, not, not, maybe a nightmare.
Holy shit.
I can't believe we did it.
Can't believe I did it.
Good times.
We told ya.
To do it up on the square and break them to you.
Got you real good with the spooks early in the stream though.
Hahaha.
You guys hear the, this is the whole thing.
Yo, that actually freaked me the fuck out.
I was, I actually thought, I actually thought you guys like, fucked with me and like, I accidentally coined my way into a horror game.
Cause I was like, oh shit, look, puzzles, very relaxed.
Legitimately, the Steam was like, puzzles, very relaxing, very nice narrative.
I was like, oh shit, that's cool.
I had four hours of sleep.
This would be a good game to test my brain out.
And then, I actually thought, I was like, oh, it's like that, it's like that Doki Literature Club shit where it was like, comedy, dating sim.
Hahaha.
Babydor.
I miss Babydor.
Also, thank you so much for the follow, Plu.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a, have a butt heart.
Thank you so much.
Alright.